under the Cova 19 pandemic America's
food supply chain is experiencing
disruption the US food industry relies
heavily on human labor to move food from
harvest to market and is only as strong
as the people who work it while the US
Department of Agriculture assures the
public that the American food supply is
strong resilient and safe the chain is
at risk because its workers are at risk
let's take a look at the different parts
of the industry that have been affected
during the pandemic growers are
experiencing unprecedented workflow
disruption farmers have been left with
fewer distribution options given the
reduction in demand from traditional
buyers such as restaurants schools and
hotels growers are having to figure out
how to adapt for example selling
wholesale doesn't work for a consumer
without a need for a 10 pound bag of
onions for onion rings crops planted
earlier in the year are either getting
left to rot plowed back into the field
or composted unpurchased milk is getting
dumped with reduced processing plant
capacity and no place for the excess
animals some farmers are euthanizing
livestock an excess of crops and meet
without buyers leave many farmers
wondering how they will stay in business
food bank donations normally an
available option have strict protocols
in place growers must meet packaging
requirements by the FDA and USDA and for
many adapting to a new model comes at
too high a price
[Music]
the current reality of the supply chain
makes it difficult for a producer to
shift the distribution process as
production plants and crop farmers look
to the government for financial relief
another sector food processing plants
are also feeling the stress of the
pandemic across the country meat prices
are now up as much as 25 percent the
growing number of major meat processing
plants are closed because of coronavirus
meatpacking plants in particular are a
hot spot workers are susceptible to
outbreaks of kovat 19 because plant
environments can be incubators for viral
spread the cool temperature which meat
is kept close proximity of workers and
the physical exertion required for the
job are all contributing factors worker
advocates are fighting for more
stretched sanitation protocols and PPE
but with sick workers off the line and
others afraid to come into work gaps in
production widen despite president
Trump's executive order to enact the
defense production Act to keep meat
processing plants open dozens have had
to halt production and closed shop
Packaging is facing its own production
woes many manufacturing companies rely
on facilities and source materials from
overseas with coronavirus closures
production and shipment delays have been
hard hit the sustainability aspect of
packaging that was a focus for many
companies will likely take a backseat
for now as consumers prioritize their
health and safety many cities and states
across the nation have banned reusable
bags fearing the spread of kovat 19 with
demand shifting towards packaging for
grocery and e-commerce purchases
manufacturers will need to reassess
where their materials are produced as
well as how food is packaged in a post
pandemic world focusing on food safety
once the food is properly packaged it
must then make the journey to retail
while there is some debate over whether
a shortage of truck drivers exists it is
increasingly clear that the current
kovat 19 crisis is adding pressure to
the transportation industry as they do
their part to keep supply chains running
according to the US Department of
Transportation truckers and truck stops
now qualify as essential businesses some
truck stops are putting in protections
that other industries have already
adopted to keep drivers on the road with
the job comes risks such as exposure to
kovat 19 limited access to supplies
delayed hazard pay and potential food
spoilage
the nation relies heavily on these
drivers delivering goods such as food
and paper products to keep stores
stocked the ripple effect through the
supply chain has placed the market to
consumer relationship in flux production
slowdowns and consumer access buying are
leading to empty grocery store shelves
and desperate customers to keep up with
demand
store owners have shifted hours to allow
for the restocking of shelves as
essential workers store employees are
also fearful for their safety some
supermarkets are adapting quickly and
taking the necessary precautions to
protect their clerks and customers while
others have come under fire for their
lack of response when employees have
tested positive for kovat 19 most stores
have adopted new safety restrictions to
include special hours for seniors social
distancing indicators and limiting the
number of shoppers allowed in a store at
a time consumers are seeing the effects
of the pandemic not only on their
grocery shelves but in their wallets as
well with higher prices and fewer
products available customers are making
changes to the way they feed their
families Americans are learning to
navigate a stay at home life by cooking
most of their meals themselves with
diminished access to meat from grocery
stores many are turning to alternative
options such as plant-based products or
direct-to-consumer delivery services
like so many industries that have been
upended by the pandemic the future of
the food supply chain is unclear what is
becoming clear is that consumers and
suppliers alike need to make greater
changes to the future of our food while
the industry relies predominantly on
human labour kovat 19 has highlighted
the need to construct a more resilient
model where the supply chain is less
susceptible to disruption and waste we
may need to reimagine the food industry
as a whole for a post pandemic world
[Music]
you